my guest today is john donovan she is a
political theologian she taught at
Oxford as well as teaching now at
University of Edinburgh and good part of
her work concerned historical as well as
theological and philosophical
investigations into the question of
human rights or rights in general now
one of the features of your work is that
you aren't so pleased as a scholar and
presumably also is a citizen with the
predominance of the language of rights
in modern Western culture political
discourse as well now that's not a very
popular position to hold rights seem to
be fundamental are fundamental to
Western economic and political
institutions and many believe that human
rights are an emerging as a new global
moral code in some ways you're you are
calling into question what lies with the
foundation of contemporary modern
Western societies and possibly at the
foundations of the emerging new world
order now before we go into your
critique of Rights which underpins
Western culture and institutions maybe
it's good for us to be clear what we
mean by rights and in particular you
were concerned with what is described as
subjective right so what are subjective
right subjective rights are our powers
to have or to demand to do something
that are attributable to subjects are
normally individual but also it may be
collective subjects
and these powers may or may not be seen
to have to conform to transcending
objective norms or loss and so the
second sentence that you just formulated
seems to suggest ah at least your or
from your work it's a questioning of the
subjective rights and so what what is
that what is the problem its objective
or subjective rights you're right to
suggest that in criticizing subjective
rights one is criticizing the historical
development of our contemporary a
liberal democratic technological society
because in that development are and I
think this is necessarily the case that
that the that the foundational right in
the notion of subject rights is the
right of the subjects own freedom and
the notion of subject to fight always
involves a proprietary understanding of
the subjects freedom as being the
subject owning are his or her actions
and spiritual and physical resources and
disposing of them in a free manner
having a full power of disposal over
them which is defensible against the
world now this I think it can be shown
this understanding of the subject as
what I have called both an economic
our entity before a political entity
this understanding of the subject as a
proprietary proprietary individual is
very basic and foundational to the
development of Western liberalism John
Locke is one of the key figures in
formulating this dis understanding of
Rights yes but in fact you can that you
can see the incipient origins of this
understanding as far back as the Canon
asst of the twelfth and thirteenth
century so I think there is quite a
continuous tradition lock what is
significant about lock it seems to me is
that while in the Canon istic tradition
and the scholastic tradition that takes
this understanding of freedom over at
freedom that is to say as the original
right it nevertheless curtails the human
powers of disposing of oneself are by
transcending objective divine and
natural laws are in Hobbes and Locke
these are the conception of these laws
are very much more attenuated than in
much of the earlier thinking right so so
if we so so can we put it in a simple
simple terms like this so i might say it
is wrong to kill and that's an objective
moral law or i might say that i have a
right to life which is something that in
hairs in me and is it my disposal as the
sub
and you see an important shift away from
understanding our moral obligations in
terms of objective rights to something
that the objective right to something
that in hairs in individuals as
individuals rights well I would say
there is an important shift that the
obligation to preserve one's life which
is an obligation that we have as
creatures of God as made by him and
loved by him that does not imply in
itself any power of self disposal ah
that subjects have and in shifting the
attention from objective to subjective
right we are shifting the attention from
essential ongoing relations that human
beings have with with God and with their
fellow human beings and these
relationships being constituted for
human dignity and for human action the
attention is being shifted from these
relationships to the individual subject
and the intrinsic or inherent powers of
the subject now you're not objecting to
the concept of individuals subjective
right am i hearing you rightly so that
if I grade my student and here she does
very good work and I give her or him a
lousy grade I'm a kind of breaking my
own promise and in some sense i'm
breaking an objective law but i'm also
harming that
I'm not also depriving the person of
something to which she or he has a right
right so there's a kind of the well I'm
I would I be without me or would you
well i would i would say that you're
depriving the person of something that
it is right for you to give to the
person I don't think that I felt the
language of justice even distributive
justice has to entail that of subjective
right but is so you don't see that you
don't see that the person that a good
student has a right to the great so that
when the grey doesn't come it's not her
objection is not simply to my not
following the precepts of proper moral
behavior toward her but rather that she
has been she herself has been wrong than
something has been taken away from her
that belongs to her namely good grade
for good paper well I can understand the
student being disappointed if the
student thinks that she has a right what
will she do in that moral outrage are
will she will she come and demand from
you a better grade and if you don't give
it will she sue you and this I think
gets to another important dimension of
subjective light why do we shift from
the language of object to subject right
I think the main attraction of the
language of subject divided apart from
the recognition of the intrinsic our
powers of the subject the intrinsic
freedom of the subject is that it a
right is
actionable it is defensible in court and
the prevalence today of and within
universities I think as everyone in the
university that teaching in the
university experiences of students not
accepting the decisions of authorities
that are disappointing and may be unjust
ah but in the past would have been
accepted perhaps complained about our
but in the end not acted upon are now
increasingly being acted upon and the
threat of litigation has become us
stifling and and very deleterious in in
manifold ways to the functioning the
proper functioning of the teaching
profession but you could you could file
a complaint even if you don't see it as
a as a question of infringement of
subjective rights its infringement
against the moral law of whom you have
happened to be a recipient in negative
negative terms and so I would rather
also that that emphasis on subjective
rights might be prone to nudge people to
seek redress but it would seem to me
also that I have a right to forego
pursuit of my own rights so so that I
can interlace very well the language of
what belongs to me appropriately right
and what I'm willing to fergal in the
same time and it may but I may even say
that it would be admirable of me to say
in Christian terms to forgive rather
than seek retributive justice yes but
you I think that's that's right your
turn that it would be admirable of me
too
is one that is a theologian I slightly
and draw my breath over and I think this
is perhaps a deeper theological problem
with rights if as I believe all right is
with God and we only have obligations
and when you've forgiven your neighbor
seven times seven you still have not
been a good servant it seems to me that
that the Christian faith to some extent
is always are pulling believers away
from preoccupations with wrongs that are
supposedly done to oneself and to a
preoccupation as much as possible with
the an obedience to God's world that is
born out of gratitude and love in a
sense of one's own inadequacy and
failures it's the you know going back to
the log in the neighbors I or the the
speck in neighbors are in the log in
one's own so I I would I i I'm I'm a
degree and I would agree with you that
that's that's the case so that
forgiveness is not it's not kind of even
super moraga Tori if we're in a
Christian an account but but rather is
an obligation a strict obligation to
fergie but I don't see necessarily how
it it is simply obligatory for me to
Fergal the right that I have rather than
calling into question those rights yeah
well it what I'm saying is that that the
the the primacy of forgiveness does not
put questions of justice at simply out
of court justice remains important in
the Christian perspective but
if one is concerned with justice to
oneself rather than justice for one's
neighbor this has been of course a you
know a theological problem in the
tradition should one be concerned and I
think that it has to be justified by by
referring it to the common good that is
that is is my complaint at this point is
my taking action at this point really
necessary to the common good or is this
is this something that all around given
a framework of moral considerations
ought to be forgotten rather then then
or at least we give them rather than
pursuit so so so if I if I understand
you correctly and I might disagree
whether it may be a right to to have a
emphasis on subjective rights as a part
of one's moral order but but but the
point that you're making is if that's
the primary reference right your for
your moral it's very difficult if I'm if
I were you here we're Isley 22 then
conceptualize and pursue the common good
right would that be one of the
difficulties with emphasis on subjective
right in the broader culture but then
the common good is difficult to achieve
and even though it's difficult to
conceptual captures conceptualizing
because I think that the the tendency of
the foundational right of freedom to
become hegemonic and basically to eat up
other conceptualizations of right and
and indeed to corrode the conception of
common goods what these goods might be
they're going to be spiritual and moral
goods in the community and a as well as
shared physical goods shared physical
spaces per
to the tendency of the foundational go
to freedom to undermine to corrode the
conceptualizing up these other goods is
something that we have seen in in
Western culture we were just talking
about education and the the tendencies
today to want to achieve increasingly a
gala tarian outcomes in an education
partly by losing a grip on what
education is really for and what it is
and you think that that's because we are
unable to living in liberal democracies
as we do giving highly praising
individual freedoms and therefore also
deviation from kind of a given given
norm whether that's communal or and so
forth that we are simply unable even to
agree on what the education ends might
be indeed indeed that's right I think
that the the the agreement are on the
the on individual freedom as the
substratum the moral substratum of
political society this is assuming a
kind of contractual contractual lyst
political framework for a free
democratic pluralistic society that
makes it difficult to to specify what
those common ends are whether they're
and while you suggest there may not be
any comments
you've made in one of your texts the
claim that if you place subjective
rights kind of at the heart of political
life that there is a threat of legal
incoherence in liberal democracies could
you could you explicate this I tell you
that is slightly different than the
question of conceptualizing common good
that we have now are discussed but
they've go something that it concerns
the functioning of the democratic system
itself well I think that that that that
but let's just take english-speaking
societies they have have inherited a
legal traditions which do the way in
which that there have been laws and and
some of them are still on the books that
assume and defend spiritual immoral
goods in the community and if if the the
rights of individuals are to choose
essentially in all the different areas
of life are being protected against
substantive goods that are presumed in
the legal traditions inherited legal
traditions it is very difficult I think
impossible in it may be impossible to
get illegal coherence out of the defense
of our of individual rights in the light
of inherited legal goods
the I think the right to choose and
practice one's faith is is perhaps a a
good indication of where our problems
may lie in in the older legal traditions
I'm partly I could I could explain this
out of the situation of Great Britain or
Canada I I have had some experience in
with the with Canadian law that the
older tradition was very much a
tradition of protecting our communal
religious rights and there has been a
shift since the Charter of Rights in a
much more secularist direction so that
there are constantly legal clashes now
between the the historic rights of
communities and the the rights of
individuals to one might say more than
anything up be free of religion in the
public really but but do you think at
least some of some of these clashes are
because our societies are increasingly
becoming pluralistic societies there is
an odd kind of a degree of homogeneity
to society that underpinned are more
unified conceptions of the common common
good and and some of those kinds of
practices so maybe maybe the question to
put it the other way around also is well
what does one do in a pluralistic floor
kind of a kind of a setting and I think
it that the liberal project is partly
driven by the idea that folks with
competing contrasting conflicting
overarching interpretations of life
somehow have to live on roughly equal
terms in the same common political
political space so short of those short
of subjective rights or emphasis subject
should subjective right how does one
deal with pluralism of societies well I
think that the first thing I would say
is that pluralism has been as much of an
ideology as a lot of a fact and if i
could shift to Great Britain I Great
Britain has several major Christian
denominations that have had historic
rights the Church of England obviously
being still fully legally established
our is that it is it remains in a
somewhat preeminent position but not
exclusive position it also great britain
also has substantial several substantial
religious minorities now it has been the
case that the members of the other
denominations than the established
church NMM and leading spokesman for
other religious minorities in great
britain have been very have have been
unsympathetic to legal changes that
would essentially move in the direction
of disestablishment of the church of
england because they they see the
umbrella of the English church
establishment as saying something
important about the public
of faith and worship in society and they
would rather that their interests are
that they're that their interest being
presented are through the the
established publicly recognized channels
are historic historically developed
channels essentially through the the
presence of the british episcopal my
lords and and and committees connected
with that rather than through some are
very different but war one might say
more aligned with contemporary
pluralistic democratic theory some some
are up more egalitarian and pluralistic
a government agency for dealing with or
political means for dealing with the
claims of different face in britain now
what having said that there is that the
non christian communities are not to do
not speak with entirely a single voice
and younger members who are what i would
say or more persuaded or perhaps even
indoctrinated by by the going language
and conceptual tea are less happy with
that but it is interesting and i just
bring it forward as a as a as a historic
and historical case that minority
religious commune
these do not always see and in Great
Britain have not seen an egalitarian
rights regime as best protecting their
interests now that is not to say that
that there there are basic liberties
that they want to sustain and where and
they want a public representation are
not suggesting they do not want the
public representation the question is
how there isn't this representation
occurs and whether it is one that
actually recognizing it recognizes
historical developments and realities as
well as as as well as the present
situation of pluralism right the issue
might be well society that the part of
the difficulty I suppose is that
societies societies are in relatively
rapid transition transition one things
about the presence of Muslim communities
in Great Britain and over the course of
a few decades the situation has
radically radically changed and
continues to me to be to be changing the
the it's clear to me to see why why they
may have stake in there not being
necessarily governmental and secular
representation of them but it's not
clear to me clear to me why they
wouldn't have more stake in themselves
or presenting themselves on equal
footing as being represented through
channels off an established church or
something or something like that well
and it the it an equal footing among the
religious communities is one way without
the historic laws of establishment which
gives the church certain historic rights
that
but that can be overturned by by a
parliament but nevertheless our
constitutional and fundamental law that
a more egalitarian situation can also be
one of dividing and ruling and there
have already been insights into what the
logistics of a more pluralistic
establishment one might say might look
like and setting religious communities
against one another is frequently not
necessarily intended but the outcome of
a kind of them a perhaps unintended
divide and rule policy of a secular
government oh I see I said that's where
that's very interesting so that kind of
kind of conflictual relations that
emphasis on subjective rights seem to
encourage and make more likely might
then be replicated if I'm reading you
rightly at the level of the relationship
between religious religious communities
and precisely for the same yes reason
and this is something that they are not
that they do have at least the more
mature spokesman do have some
understanding of now your your position
your critique of subjective rights may
not find resonance is strong resonances
in many of the circles in the Western
tradition world because it's so it has
become a such a predominant language the
people i think realize also its problems
and it's its difficulties right but but
when one when one looks at the other
religious traditions it looks like they
may quite well align yourself themselves
with a kind of position that you are
advocating because often tradition of
subjective rights is foreign to their
traditions whether that's buddhist
tradition
whether that's Islamic traditions though
the language of Rights is present yes
it's not really language of subjective
right so type didn't have developed over
the course of centuries seen in this in
the West one might say natural
subjective rights it's not that then
universalistic language so that so that
so that affinities can be presumably
presumably created and one might argue
against the position written that who
where I've just posted it actually your
position might be hold more promise of
some kind of interfaith in the chemical
agreement yes I well I think it does
actually well I I think that that a
conversation among face are on human
dignity and human justice is perhaps a
will allow a broader spectrum of
theological considerations on all sides
and other possibilities for convergences
then then the rights languages language
does that I think the right the language
of Rights throws up problems that are
don't have to be there well it can
create you know obstacles that then have
to be overcoming them in religious
dialogue whereas there are other ways of
approaching the dialogue through I
suppose out what I would say the more
that the longer Christian tradition of
the west which focuses on divine human
relations the divine Commandments human
bedient principles of right created and
the goods of creation and redemption
political justice
and and divine and human law that this
language is is perhaps in some ways more
universal then then it but that the
language of rights and not just where
presumably not just the language of the
way of framing moral moral
considerations but also in terms of the
content indeed their significant
overlaps between between some of the
major religious traditions now toward
the end of our conversation here I'd
like to return back to the to the
question of religious liberty and how
would how would that question how would
you parse that question normal it has
been pursued but fairly weak vigorously
in terms of religious religious rights
as a subjective right right from your
perspective how this religious liberty
look like is there something like a
right to choose one's religion or right
to change one's religion that has been a
significant dispute partly partly
correlated with the way in which wonder
stands the self and it sells belonging
to community that's been debate within
the Christian tradition but it has been
also debated between various religions
including Islam and Christianity ah it
there have of course been historical
changes in different differences of
nuance and the Christian tradition and
indeed arguments over the extent of of
individual freedom in relation to the
the common good that that that the
authorities of the church have conceived
and and and are imposing or have imposed
to some extent through secular law to
civil law and it seems to me that
that the the Christian faith does entail
the individual freedom are to embrace
the faith that one may believe that
faith only comes through the operation
the the Holy Spirit but the individual
will has to consent and that has to be
free consent and therefore there should
not be constraints there should not be
civil constraints on that consent
individual should not be forced to be
members of a church I mean that is
perhaps the the absolutes of
non-negotiable a freedom that that are
Christians and therefore by implication
all people should enjoy in relation to
their face that leaves still quite
flexibly open the question of how the
common good which may entail privileges
for certain religious communities out of
historic tradition and the end the face
of the majority or the faith of of the
work the majority of citizens that may
be distributed among several faiths or
one faith or one churches or several
face it the the freedom of individuals
individual belief and practice does not
answer that problem of how those how
that what the institutional relations
should look like
what justice with lies and there it
seems to me what is necessary is a
delicate balance between the common good
and the the the individual good and that
may mean for example that only the major
religious communities run church schools
or faith schools with government funding
that that funding is not available for
all of the perhaps 30 different small
sex that might be available in it in
that that that might be present in a
particular society but it is thought
that the presence of the love of faith
in the public realm is best suited by
just the larger communities having this
privilege of funding for education I
take it that so that's it would regard
to particular phase that's a that's a
Prudential judgment about the
relationship between kind of history and
majoritarian situations rather than
principle judgment about this particular
faith having serving in a better way
common good or I'm trying to avoid
language of rights right well it is it
is or is it a principle know it's a it's
a principle judgment about the presence
of faith in the public ground on the but
it could be anything it could be so
let's think of let's think of Great
Britain or a lot of becoming becoming
majority Muslim yes does that from your
perspective that means shift if it were
to be if the country were to become a
heaven Muslim majority then I are unless
the muslim-majority wanted from the
continuance of English church
establishment I don't
that it could continue visit the unless
a a small minority is going to impose by
force it's it's a public support for
faith on a majority then that support is
no longer viable I mean at the present
time the there is the the the issue
would rather be to what extent the
government of Great Britain will support
Muslim schools as well as the historic
church of england at Roman Catholic and
Jewish schools the Church of England and
and the Roman Catholic being I think
probably fairly on a par now in terms of
the educational institutions that are
run by by both
so equality notwithstanding right so
there's our in sense of equality and
it's derived from the nature of way you
read the nature of face is that right
rather than of some inherent yes right
of a person indeed indeed I think that
they the adjectives inherent has to go
from my point of view I see well on this
of this challenging note of the
adjectives inherent or also i suppose
subjective in that that sense having
having to go i will want to thank you
for for this conversation about writes
about pluralistic societies and about
the goodness of the common good thank
you thank you